hey feminists stop please stop the myth
that women get paid less for the exact
same job as men comes from one poorly
interpreted statistic that merely
compares the median earnings of women
versus men that stat did not include
people of different genders working in
the same industry the same job or even
the same amount of hours so why are
women paid less the number one
determining factor is that women have
babies oh are you saying that's all
we're good for no just that in general
women are the ones found to be with
child you know wombs and what have you
so not only does that mean less time in
the workforce but women are also more
likely to trade in dangerous job
situations high stress or traveling in
exchange for more Mommy friendly
positions it's why virtually all the
most dangerous job occupations like iron
worker or logger are male and
92% of work-related deaths in 2012 were
men so you may complain about lower pay
we die in addition men are twice as
likely to work a 40-hour work